yes because I cannot continue my work
for for two or three or three reasons
first of all
I have a suspension and this suspension
is just starting
and is going to continue I'm sure
because if you can't see
how it was done
is going to continue
at the same time
I think that the Federation
is not a question about if I can support
or know this mediatic tsunami
it's about to know how it's going to
affect to the Royal Spanish food
Federation and I love my country and I
love football and I don't want damage
for them
another
I think about it is we
we are running for the World Cup in 2013
we made an incredible
a job during the last fun and health
yes we started Fernando Rome as the
president of Portuguese Federation and
me more than five years ago with this
um
I think that
Now is better for this bit
for me to go out and I spoke
no directly but to refer and they all
agree then I cannot be egoist and to
take the chair and not to move myself
because the situation changed so much
from the moment I say I'm not going to
resign and now saying so so much in
three weeks I don't now is incredible
how
how fast can we sung Institution